jean-luc Picard is back he made not and
I stress may not be a captain anymore he
may not be the Jean Luc that you
recognize and know so well it may be a
very different individual someone who
has been changed by his experiences
twenty years in the past which is more
or less exactly the time between the
very last movie nemesis and today we
have no scripts as yet we're just
talking talking talking storylines it
will be I promise you I guarantee it
something very very different but it
will come to you with the same passion
and determination and love of the
material and love of our followers and
our fans exactly as we had it before
everybody it's Charlie make it so
Captain Picard
is getting a new TV show although as he
says he might not be a captain when it
picks up because 20 years have gone by
so we got to freak out about this if
you're brand new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos of
course like whenever this comes I will
do videos for it as long as people want
the thing with Discovery so far is that
people kind of fell off during season
one it just didn't like what they were
doing trying to battle start up but it
looks like they're course-correcting a
little bit with some of these other
shows that they're developing quick
ketchup if you haven't been following
any Star Trek news recently CBS a while
ago announced that it was developing a
whole bunch of new Star Trek TV shows
all over the timeline with different
groups of characters stuff from next gen
stuff from the original series there's
even a brand new animated series that
they're developing right now they're
just trying to do more Star Trek on TV
that's not necessarily just Star Trek
discovery one of those shows that they
announced was a Captain Picard show with
Patrick Stewart and people were like
that's never gonna happen Patrick
Stewart is not gonna come back to do
more Star Trek what would that even look
like would it be said in the future
would it be an alternate timeline so the
video that I put at the beginning of
this is from the Star Trek convention in
Las Vegas right now so this was him just
a couple hours ago on stage announcing
Picard is back I cut it way down but he
did say that earlier this year CBS
contacted him the people that are
producing Star Trek discovery are also
the same people that are developing this
Picard show they made him an offer that
he couldn't refuse which he then
promptly refused he said you know I just
I can't do this for pretty much the same
reason why most actors don't come back
to do sequels like they just don't want
to rehash the plot of the things they
originally did so I think the Patrick
Stewart initially was concerned that
they just wanted him to do next gen
continues maybe Captain Picard on the
bridge of the enterprise
II just going around the galaxy like
they did during next gen and he didn't
want to do that show again the thing
that turned him around though is that
he's been re watching a lot of his old
next gen episodes and remembered how
much hope that brought to people this
optimistic view of the future and how
dark the world has gotten in real life
in recent years so he said he felt like
that deserved to exist in the world so
he wants to
another show in the spirit of next-gen
like he said in the clip at the
beginning of this the ethos the tone of
next-gen doing a show like that but not
necessarily just rehashing the plot of
next-gen important details though this
is said in the primetime line 20 years
after the events of Star Trek nemesis he
said he might not be a captain but
remember even though it's not
technically canon anymore the future
Picard that we saw in the series finale
had not been a captain for a while even
though he was suffering from a
degenerative neurological condition so
just assumed that in the main timeline
now things went down differently so he
is still that old man Picard
but without necessarily spoiling
anything he made it sound like he would
be acting a little bit like say old
ambassador Spock did during next-gen
like moving around the galaxy trying to
affect change without necessarily being
a captain or an admiral
but at times co-opting the services of
the enterprise and the other people that
you saw pop up during the series that
whole plot with Spock trying to reunite
the Vulcans with the Romulans with some
hardcore stuff but remember the episodes
where Picard would indulge his love of
archaeology and they would uncover big
mysteries about the universe think of
this new older Picard is a
problem-solver in that sense sort of
indulging a lot of those scientific
curiosities while at the time trying to
help people on a very large scale so you
get to have that fun Picard sense of
humor but he also gets to be a little
cantankerous because he's an old man now
so you get the tone of classic Picard
and you have the chance of all the other
next gen actors coming back to guest
star they haven't announced to the
supporting cast is but why would you do
a next gen show with Picard said in the
future if you didn't plan on bringing
other next gen actors back like bring
back old man Worf bring back Beverly
Crusher bringing back the new version of
data that they created at the end of
Nemesis you have to imagine that in 20
years he's probably gotten closer to
becoming more like original data but you
have LaForge
there's still a lot of Star Trek actors
from next gen that are very active today
some of them are working behind the
camera more than in front of it but like
Jonathan Frakes for instance is still
very involved with the Star Trek
franchise so it'd be pretty easy for him
to come back as Riker could you imagine
what the new version of old man Riker is
like there were so many times in Star
Trek history where you got to see
versions of that
in the series finale where he had become
Admiral Riker like he was even more of a
military man than Picard was but the way
they played off of each other was always
so great so even if he's not a main
character just please let them bring
Rikers beard back the other funny thing
too is everybody's reacting to this this
morning Wil Wheaton was like oh my god
this is so amazing you know of course
people took the opportunity to harass
him that would be interesting if they
tried to make Wesley Crusher cool again
I think that will Wheaton would be down
to participate if they wanted him but I
think it would just depend on what they
would want to do with the characters
like what is the state of the galaxy
when this series picks up because of
things being so dark in the real world
right now is what inspired Patrick
Stewart to make this series that it
implies that that tone will also flow
into the series so like there will be
some really heavy going down in the
galaxy but the beauty of this being 20
years in the future is that alliances
can shift so much in that time but the
other backup thing to think about too is
is whether or not they're gonna rope in
any ds9 actors now obviously they were
crossover people like Worf but I'm
talking about pure ds9 people like what
about Kira
what about Bashir what about O'Brien
what's going on with those characters I
think a lot of that just depends on what
kind of story they're gonna tell and
just like the other series I'm expecting
this to be 13 episodes instead of like
24 25 26 like the classic next-gen
series so as Patrick Stewart says
they're still hammering out story ideas
right now we'll probably hear about
casting sometime early next year maybe
they'll start shooting by next summer so
it might be 2020 before we get to see
this TV show and I'm assuming that it
would be on CBS all access because most
of the new Trek spin-off shows that they
announced they were developing were
intended for the CBS all access service
but if you haven't been keeping up with
discovery season 2 is Captain Pike
coming on taking command and then going
out to discover things like you would
see in the classic series
Captain Christopher Pike request
permission to come aboard well commander
this is awkward but the best way to give
into a cold stream to jump right in
I'm here to stay commander the discovery
under regulation 19 Section C your
directive is only instituted with an
evident threat is detected the
Federation sensors picked up seven red
verse spread out across more than 30,000
light-years these mysterious signals are
beyond anything we understand is it a
greeting a declaration of malice let's
find out
aye sir
hedid so it's a little more of a tonal
shift they crank the colors up a little
bit it's not quite so drab but those of
you that did not like discovery so we'll
find out more about that soon
but leave all your reactions in the
comments below old man picard TV show
let the memes flow the fandom needs new
Picard memes and they shall get them
there's a new game of Thrones that I'm
working on there's a whole bunch of
marvel and DC stuff happening we're
still in the middle of the summer so
just leave all your video requests in
the comments below
but click here for brand new Avengers 4
and click here for all those infinity
war deleted scenes thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]